BoBonsoir à vous trois!
MeMeurtre du petit Thomas Trude,
1616 ans dimanche soir. Ça a
cocontinué. Ça a pris quand même
unun certain temps avant que les
réréactions politiques n'arrive.
LaLa mairesse est allée en fin
d'd'après-midi.
ElElle part des armes à feu. Je
vavais vous la faire entendre et
jeje veux vous entendre ensuite.
ElElle dit qu'on va pas régler a
totout seul à Montréal cette
ququestion des armes à feu.
VAVALÉRIE PLANTE,
mamairesse de Montréal
- - Bien sûr, il y a Montréal.
NoNous sommes la métropole, mais
ilil y a également d'autres
vivilles, également, où il y a
unune recrudescence d'incidents
avavec des armes à feu. Mais,
évévidemment, on va se le dire,
ilil n'en demeure pas moins que
c'c'est le gouvernement fédéral
ququi a la responsabilité entiè,
lala capacité de dire : "les ars
chchez nous, les arme de poing,
c'c'est non. C'est interdit".
D'D'augmenter les peines pour
popossession d'armes, il y a
bebeaucoup de choses qui
popourraient être faites pour
didissuader des jeunes, des jeus
dede 16 ans de se retrouver avec
unune arme, de les commander par
InInternet ou autre chose.
- - Elle remet de la pression sr
OtOttawa.
- - Oui. Mais en même temps, la
prpromesse libérale a changé das
lele temps. Au départ elle voult
reremettre dans le camp des vils
lala responsabilité de bannir ou
papas ses armes.
EnEn campagne électorale les
lilibéraux ont changé de ton. Is
onont dit qu'ils pourraient donr
cecette responsabilité à l'échee
prprovinciale.
LeLes provinces pourraient décir
dede bannir les armes et surtout
leleur territoire. Et les libérx
onont même promis 1 milliard de
dodollars pour faire ça, pour
aiaider les provinces, les
acaccompagner.
MaMaintenant, est-ce que ce sera
fafait? On a déjà vu les promess
élélectorales libérales en matie
dede contrôle des armes à feu qi
n'n'ont pas été réalisées.
MaMais clairement les libéraux t
prprogressé dans leur pensée à t
égégard ils ont bien vu qu'à
l'l'échelle de la municipalité,a
nene pouvait pas fonctionner.
- - Elle ne peut pas régler ça
totoute seule. Le problème des
ararmes à feu, c'est une patate
chchaude avec laquelle les
popoliticiens jonglent depuis
totoujours, surtout depuis le
drdrame de polytechnique.
PaParce qu'ils ont peur qu'en
alallant trop loin, il y a un px
popolitique à payer. On l'a vu u
cocours de la dernière année,
c'c'était une espèce de jeu
d'd'évasion, à qui en ferait le
momoins possible pour ne pas
efeffaroucher les électeurs.
D'D'abord, M. Trudeau voulait
coconfier ça aux villes. C'est
évévident que ça n'a pas de bon
sesens. On ne peut pas avoir une
popolitique différente pour chae
viville.
LeLes provinces, c'est déjà miex
mamais il reste que les frontiès
ininternationales, la contreban,
c'c'est Ottawa qui peut s'occupr
dede ça.
LeLes frontière interprovinciale
sosont théorique. On peut très
bibien acheter une arme à Ottawa
pupuis traverser au Québec et ve
veversa.
NoNormalement, ça devrait être
OtOttawa qui s'occupe de ça. Ça
veveut pas dire que les villes,
leles corps policiers des villes
etet des provinces nonon pas auà
cocollaborer à une politique
glglobale, mais c'est Ottawa qui
dodoit l'établir.
- - Le trafic d'armes à feu à
MoMontréal et ailleurs, ça datee
plplusieurs décennies. On arrive
ququand même très tard dans la
chchute si je puis dire.
OuOui ça devrait être une
ininitiative fédérale
papancanadienne c'est évident.
MaMais je ne voudrais pas non ps
ququ'on réduise la situation que
l'l'on vit à Montréal. C'est un
prproblème important, mais le vi
prproblème, c'est la violence.
C'C'est une violence qui est
paparfois arme à feu, parfois pr
ararme blanche. On en voit de ps
enen plus, des couteaux.
UnUn des trois jeunes d'ailleurà
etet des blessés par couteau.
EtEt dans des quartiers qui sont
dédélaissés, dans des quartierùu
ilil y a des problèmes sociaux
imimportants.
OuOui, on peut sortir de notre
chchapeau un élément comme le ft
HaHarel Valérie Plante et dire :
onon règle cela est en règle tot
lele reste. On sait très bien qe
cece n'est pas vrai, qu'il y a u
dudu laisser-aller sur le plan
sosocial et économique. Moi je
viviens de Saint-Michel.
JeJe comprends comment c'est
dedevenu une marmite.
JeJe n'ai pas vu les politiciens
ememmêlés quand c'était le temps
dede le faire de manière
prproductive et constructive.
J'J'espère qu'ils vont le père.
- - On a l'impression peut-être
quque cette fois-ci, Thomas
TrTrudel, comme ça avait été le
cacas avec le jeune qui avait éé
tutué lors de l'explosion de la
jejeep dans la guerre des motar.
enen tout cas, on verra.
JeJe veux aller tout de suite ou
CHCHSLD. Enquête de la coronair.
LaLa question qu'elle pose, c'et
lala question qu'on a en tête
dedepuis le début de cette cris:
ququand on a préparé les hôpita,
onon a une situation du Docteur
HaHarruda qui a été interrogé ds
lele cadre de cette enquête de a
cocoronaire.
VoVoici la réponse :
auautrement dit, est-ce que cete
enenquête de la coronaire va nos
apapprendre des choses? José,
c'c'est encore la question qui
rereste en suspens. On a dit
prpréparer les hôpitaux et on a
l'l'impression qu'on s'est dit :
adadvienne que pourra dans les
CHCHSLD.
- - C'est lala boîte de pandorea
cocoronaire est en train de
l'l'ouvrir. La protectrice du
cicitoyen en avait ouverte une
papartie dans les derniers mois.
OnOn a appris à la a connaître
évévidemment dans le dossier de
JoJoyce Echaquan : elle ne
lalaissera pas aller ce dossier
fafacilement.
C'C'est sûr que pour le
gogouvernement Legault, c'est un
boboulet parce que la première
vavague au Québec, ça a été une
cacatastrophe. Le piètre état ds
CHCHSLD qui avaient été délaisss
papar les gouvernements précédes
l'l'expliquent en partie, mais
c'c'était le cas aussi en Ontar.
EtEt proportionnellement, il y a
eueu beaucoup moins de morts das
leleur centre de soins de longue
dudurée qu'au Québec. Est-ce qul
y y a eu des problèmes spécifiqs
icici qui sont aussi redevablesu
gogouvernement actuel. C'est por
çaça que ça prend une vraie
enenquête publique.
J'J'ai l'impression que la
cocoronaire va probablement le
rerecommander elle-même. Il faut
alaller au fond de ça.
OnOn a eu une enquête publique
popour le viaduc de la Concorde.
LLà, on a eu plus de 5000
QuQuébécois morts dans des
coconditions absolument atroces.
SiSi ça ne mérite pas une enquêe
pupublique, on se demande bien
popourquoi on en tiendrait sur
ququoi que ce soit d'autre. Swih
elelle a dit que si ça avait été
dedes enfants, on ne serait en
trtrain de hurler.
ElElle pose des questions
didifficiles en effet à des sou-
miministre, au Docteur Harruda,
etetc. on a l'impression qu'elle
nene lâchera pas le morceau et e
leles explications qu'on lui fa,
çaça ne la satisfaisait pas. Ily
a a quelque chose qui manque là-
dededans.
- - Je comprends que ça la
sasatisfasse pas. C'est vrai, oa
apappris à la connaître. Mais on
cocommence à connaître le Docter
HaHarruda aussi. Sébastien Bovet
cece midi parlait du vocabulaire
haharrudien.
OnOn a des communes pensées...
cocomment, comme une pensée?
OnOn n'a pasas une pensée.
OnOn se rend compte que Monsieur
HaHarruda nous dit : on avait ue
ididée au mois de février... ila
eueu un comité qui s'est penché
spspécifiquement sur les CHSLD u
momois d'avril : qu'est-ce qui
s's'est fait entre les deux? Ily
a a quelque chose qui n'a pas de
bobon sens.
IlIl y avait le problème de la
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre qu'on
coconnaissait qu'on ne pouvait
rérésoudre du jour au lendemain
mamais tout le problème de
l'l'équipement. Et après une
ététernité avant que le Québec e
dédécide à en commander.
LaLa Colombie-Britannique l'avat
fafait bien avant.
EfEffectivement quand le Québec
c'c'est décidé, la guerre battat
soson plein mais il y avait des
gegens qu'il avait prévus et qui
sosont passés avant nous.
NoNon, il y a beaucoup de choseà
fofouiller avant. Et je suis tot
àà fait d'accord depuis toujours
ququ'une enquête publique
s's'impose.
J'J'ai comme l'impression que ça
vava bien par arriver mais que e
gogouvernement va s'organiser pr
quque disons... ça débouche pasr
grgrand-chose, certainement pas
avavant la prochaine élection.
- - Hélène, votre vision d'Otta.
MoMonsieur Trudeau dans ce dossr
avavait fait miroiter des
coconditions pour plus de
fifinancement dans les CHSLD etl
rérépète souvent : c'est pas pae
quque ça été un exemple de bonne
gegestion Québec. Comment vous
vovoyez tous?
- - C'est pas parce que Monsieur
TrTrudeau veut imposer des norms
quque comme par magie elles
s's'appliqueront.
OnOn sait bien que les raisons
popour lesquelles ça ne fonctioe
papas dans les CHSLD, c'est pare
ququ'il y a un manque de personl
auauquel on n'est pas capable...
ququ'on n'est pas capable de
rérésoudre. Je mettrai un petit
bébémol par rapport à tout ce
ququ'on a entendu.
IlIl faut quand même prendre gae
dede ne pas trop juger le penseà
lala lumière de ce que l'on sait
auaujourd'hui mais qu'on ne savt
papas nécessairement à l'époque.
JeJe trouve quand même intéresst
ququand les autorités nous diset
: : on en avait un plan, mais sy
a a certaines solutions qui
fafaisaient parti du plan qui se
sosont révélé être la source du
prproblème.
JeJe pense par exemple à
l'l'interdiction des aidants
nanaturels d'avoir accès aux
CHCHSLD. On pensait que comme ç,
onon allait protéger nos persons
ââgéesé
fifinalement ça a été une source
d'd'un grand problème évidemmen.
NoNos personnes âgées se sont
reretrouvées sans aide. L'idée e
nene pas les envoyer à l'hôpital
ouou de les retourner des hôpitx
dadans les CHSLD, on pensait que
c'c'était parce que ce serait à
l'l'hôpital qu'il y aurait des
didizaines de milliers
d'd'hospitalisations et que ce
serarait là le ground zero.
FiFinalement, on a plutôt envoyé
nonos personnes âgées vers
l'l'enfer.
- - Oui, mais c'est parce que ça
fafait parti des nombreux morcex
ququi mamanquent opposer le ...
lolorsque Monsieur Harruda disat
ququ'il avait une pensée, ça vet
didire qu'ils étaient au couran,
etet que c'était ce qui circulat
àà travers le monde. La décision
a a quand même été prise de vidr
dedes hôpitaux comme on dit il y
avavait des humains ququ'on a
cacatapultés dans des CHSLD. Le
fifils d'une mère qui est morte
cocomme ça, il a dit qu'on avait
enenvoyé sa mère à l'abattoir
paparce qu'elle y est morte de a
COCOVID-19 dans un CHSLD.
MaMais comment on a pu décider a
enen même temps qu'on n'a pas
prpréparé ses milieux de vie ete
sosoins?
LeLe vrai problème, il est là.
O On sait très bien, lorsque
l'l'histoire sur les CHSLD privs
HeHerron est sortie, c'est là qe
totout à coup est apparu.
IlIl y avait comme une omerta ds
lele système.
IlIl y a beaucoup de problèmes
ququ'il faut étudier.
JeJe vois pas comment va pouvoir
ararriver au fond de cette
ququestion, parce que ça
ququestionne tout le système de
sasanté, tout le réseau complet,
sasans une vraie enquête publiq.
- - Il y a un problème plus
prprofond dans les CHSLD,
l'l'absence de véritables soins
mémédicaux.
PlPlusieurs médecins le disent.l
y y a plein de soins qu'on ne
dodonne pas dans ses milieux et
ququi devrait l'être.
DoDonc il y a quelque chose qui
dadate d'avant la pandémique dot
êêtre réglé et explique le fait
ququ'on s'est retrouvé comme ça
inincapable de soigner ces gens-
llà.
- - Ces questions illustrent bin
lala nécessité que ce serait bin
ququ'on est tous des réponses.
- - C'est vrai qu'il y a une
lilivraison de problème, mais on
paparle aussi de donner de l'eau
auaux pensionnaires.
adadjointe qui est précisément
reresponsable des aînés au
miministère qui disait : on ne
sasavait pas qui n'était pas
hyhydraté.
avavait pas de personnel mais on
nene savait pas qui n'était pas
hyhydraté. Mais il n'y a pas de
pepersonnel, il n'y a personne
popour les hydrater.
didire manque de personnel, ce
n'n'est pas satisfaisant.
- - Même de lire le livre de noe
cocollègue Alec Castonguay,
papartie-là, on n'a pas toutes s
réréponses, c'est pas vrai parce
quque quand préparer les hôpita,
ququ'est-ce qu'on faisait au mêe
momoment, pour les CHSLD?
- - Oui mais rappelons que c'étt
unune crise sanitaire. Il y avat
unune cellule de crise qui exise
totoujours au sommet de tout.
JeJe pense qu'il faut savoir
ququelles sont les décisions qui
onont été prises par cette celle
dede crise et qui sont ensuite
dedescendus dans l'appareil.
PePeut-être que le trio santé qe
çaça ne fonctionnait pas tout à
fafait comme ça
ququ'une grande partie de
l'l'explication et à la cellulee
crcrise.
- - Est-ce que le leadership de
ErErin O'Toole est contesté... l
esest contesté par S
coconservatrice. Est-ce sérieux
susur un large spectre?
- - On va la prendre au cours ds
prprochains jours. Ce qu'on nous
didit c'est que c'est une... c't
bibien organisé. On pense à
plplusieurs sorties
sisix prochains mois.
leleadership de Erin O'Toole. En
mmême temps il faut quand même
prprendre en note
plplusieurs gros noms qui sont
sosortis, à sa défense,
c'c'est vrai que ça fait
exextrêmement mal.
RaRappelez-vous Andrew Scheer, a
avavait pris du temps avant qu'n
lului montre la porte préélecti.
IlIl n'est pas encore sorti du
bobois.
- - On aura le temps d'en
rereparler.
MeMerci beaucoup!